ae
posso dizer que até aqui rapidamente se
quer que o voluntarismo absoluta
legislatur obrigado
um dos pilares na ponta eu vou colar
quando você chorou
estou lá dentro obrigado
mas para o lado mas por outro lado é
ótimo
muito obrigado nos rege por favor
vamos passar a vir à primeira vista pode
ter por ser que tudo se estão a
apresentação acontece por aí que guarda
de honra é mesmo real
o chef membros da guarda nacional
republicana que contam um caixão de
portugal são verdades guardas da gnr
contratados pela organização para
participarem no projecto teatral
o enterro de portugal é contínua 17 de
agosto e foi uma das iniciativas da
capital do país de cultura guimarães
só que esta partida oficial da gnr
caso mal estar na instituição levou à
abertura de um processo de atribuição
dos que terminou agora com isso
ressaltou o comandante territorial de
braga é apesar de existir uma
autorização genérica para a participação
da guarda em eventos de iniciativa
cultural
o comandante terá considerado que este é
em particular não se enquadrava nesse
contexto o grupo laboratório ou nós que
assinou a representação já lamentou a
decisão da gnr afirma que o chefe
membros da guarda foram pagos tal fala
acontece no jogo de futebol
o objetivo do funeral era alertar para a
situação do país com criatividade
defendem o plano também a ressurreição
olá ana carvalho muito votar agora que
está uma questão é polêmica é tricky
várias questões aliás não é só uma
pessoa exatamente uma das questões
interessantes é fazer o funeral num no
âmbito de uma das composições produzidas
por um ex presidente da república mas
sofre intensa pressão artística agora a
greve nos entreguem esse cacho que hoje
a mulher muito tempo já havia vencido há
mais tempo ou vista janelas da alma
morreu tá doido que está uma vergonha
saiu sozinho no meio da multidão chamado
manuel salazar e vêm ter comigo numa ii
no mutirão em choque a mãe embora isso
numa da capital europeia da cultura
quinze dias depois o comandante da
guarda um coronel é segurado por causa
dessa intervenção
desta forma estes filmes possibilidade
foi apenas o culminar de anos de
trabalho fazem os 10 anos
fato o primeiro mais - com ele uma preta
foi em abril de 2005 ea minha intenção
foi discutir a discutir portugal e isso
tem feito ao longo destes anos com este
projecto com mais - fazer observações
sobre a sociedade em que vivemos sobre
os modos políticos sociais e econômicos
mas acima de tudo estimular a ação e pra
rua fazer as pessoas pensarem em fazer
as suas entrevistas
há dez anos atrás e eu também estava a
passar uma crise de identidade
em relação ao design comunicação que era
o curso que estava a tirar e quando
acabei o curso a necessidade de
contrariar tudo aqui o canal aprender eu
sentia que o design seu papel era o
peito ar o sistema em que vivemos
de flore a um sistema em que estamos
o evento criado mais - como uma marca
que fossem intimar cá uma marca de
qualidade
uma marca que vai ser aberta à discussão
e então não vai mais gente para a rua
como entrave na rua fazer o ato prático
toda esta teoria vírus ou utilizar a rua
como meu esporte como minha tela começar
a alterar o espaço público como normal
estimular as pessoas a reclamação também
e ao início ou mais - era um produto em
si era só mais - não vi as frases não vi
as intervenções na via por formas eram
mais - um produto leste e logo desde o
início como seria ter esse contato com o
público e foi isso que mais trouxe muito
nesse trabalho e é isso que eu vou falar
hoje são várias situações que foram
acontecendo ao longo destes anos os
media tiveram uma atenção eu com mais -
deram atenção ao projeto conquistou esta
plataforma mas perceber logo numa
primeira fase qual é o impacto mais -
estava terços não tão a observação dos
media as provas na ação direta das
pessoas na rua forma anônima e
questionava as pessoas se nos últimos
tempos tenha visto algum símbolo
estivesse chamando a atenção ea verdade
é que 70% das pessoas falavam mais - e e
70% de 70% esse grupo eu continuava a
perguntar o que sentiam o que achavam
que era que seria aquela até o fim
chrome para as pessoas e sentir que eram
apresentações dos seus membros o mais -
era o suporte daquilo que as pessoas
pensavam como a cidade era suporto mais
- isso foram algumas das inspirações
e foi com com este propósito que eu
comecei continue a espalhar o trabalho
abre para os prazos e comecei a perceber
que sem pensar nisso é as pessoas
sentiam desmotivados também elas
entrevista
e é precisamente esse o meu objetivo
criar de ao criar a ação não é muito
tempo fui fazer esse trabalho numa rua
do porto e mais tarde ele falar isso
esse trabalho durante a tarde
passado uma hora quando lá cheguei já
estava assim eu percebi que alguém
estava queria conversar comigo então não
sei se fui lá e deixei isso
mas o construtor dez prédios desta obra
estava a correr dentro desse prédio
conseguiu ser mais inteligente e
conseguiu pintado mal branco quando
tinha dito que era proibido tentar tomar
branco sem saber então voltei lá outra
vez no dia a seguir
e mais uma vez o construtor conseguiu
bater minha 0
é importante este álbum ficou por aqui
a cobra foi antecipada em um só precisa
de dois mas interessante que isso foi no
dia que estava pendurada a roupa é um
senhor passa por mim e pergunta foi você
que pintaram aquela frase aqui há uns
dias e nós fomos um sim você nem sabe
quanto tocou pra ver esse carro que não
estava estacionado nessa altura esse era
o meu pai meu pai faleceu há alguns
meses e foi curadora vida toda
esta praça terá uma hora e tocou dessa
forma uma pessoa que passava na rua
mas nem sempre as coisas são
despropositadas também criou algumas
intervenções para estimular essas são as
pessoas porque as pessoas a pensar por
elas próprias agir nesse projeto seria
destruir as letras da parede como causa
uma praça
cerca de 300 caracteres e desafiar as
pessoas a escrever o futuro e as pessoas
foram escrevendo seu futuro foi
escrevendo as suas mensagens com os
critérios e andava na praça com as
letras um a todos e foram muitos anos as
mensagens das pessoas conseguiram
construir mais interessante ainda foi
quase uma conclusão poética que eu posso
tirar esta intervenção a sete pontos já
não havia mais critério e escrever
estavam todos a ser usados por outras
fases entre as pessoas que vinham tinham
que retirar do futuro das obras para
construir o seu então fica aquela ideia
poética do que o nosso futuro não é nada
sem futuro dos outros
neste momento a desenvolver um projecto
que aproveito para vos convidar a todos
a câmara do porto cedeu uma parede no
centro do porto e três mil ações para
pintar e eu tenho o porto novo pessoas
podem pintar agora são usuais e partir
de junho os terá um maior painel
coletivo da cidade vai estar presente na
baixa com vida os dois já se quiserem
participar aos domingos de manhã junto à
estação dos ambientes a virem pintar
nossas ruas e tirar partido das
instituições é interessante sete pontos
comecei a perceber que além das dirceu
também poderia representar se iria levar
muito a ver com o objecto mais - no
clássico desta forma nesta frase também
sem isto aqui em inglês pode ter sido o
significado e representar
percebi que podia perfeitamente
apresentar e tirar partido destas
instituições e reforma ea conjuntura e
da forma como se impunha a realidade da
esquerda à câmara municipal de lisboa
quando teve uma exposição em lisboa em
2003 e disse que ia eu acho que vejo o
nome da exposição ea data
escrevi esta frase está tendo essa ideia
que eu podia esconder uma vista toda a
gente afinal de contas a receber muito
mais fácil pintar à noite ao intervir à
noite a entrevista dia à noite
é uma pessoa que tal aprender a pintar
durante o dia com na confusão certeza
tem autorização
e foi isso que eu fiz em plena rua do
alecrim
ao meio-dia centro de lisboa cheia de
movimentos como amigo 2 500 dois
capacetes
estive a vontade de pintar o silêncio
fight no período das manifestações em
2012 juntando a esta ideia da ação e
representação
eu vou terminar com esta peça foi a
pessoa que eu consegui juntar todos os
instrumentos estava em imagens antes do
funeral
segundo o capitão em 3 a 1 precisava
testar uma faca nas costas ao fazer
redes
precisava de filmar essa ação que sentia
liguei para a produção de guimarães e
fazendo passar por um produtor de cinema
não consegui autorização comum em três
amigos mal as gruas quer mais casas em
manaus maués mais carros mais filhos mas
não sei quem é certa manhã
vamos gastar tudo fazer links com o
policial as no paços do concelho às
difíceis do café mais próximo
tivemos duas horas à volta do caí
espetar a faca tira faca consegue tirar
aqui filmando a qual a uma convocatória
e as pessoas a participarem para
entrarem e fazerem parte desta
intervenção
então aí consegui juntar tudo aquilo que
eu acho que fim um carinho a mais - não
só é um estimulador pensamento crítico
mas também o motivo a votação das contas
do estado final
muito obrigado